what kind of bombing was this this was
an attack on a soft target frankly if
you look at international comparisons we
got lucky this could have been much
worth worse in terms of more towards
like fatalities yes well the FBI had
been asked by the Russian government to
look into one of the brothers here
Lindsey Graham the senator actually
questioned whether the FBI fumbled here
listen I want to know how the FBI or the
system dropped the ball when he was
identified as a potential terrorist and
the fact that we could not track him has
to be fixed there's people like this
that you don't want to let out of your
sight and this was a mistake
I don't know if our laws are
insufficient or the FBI failed but we're
at war radical Islamist and we need to
up our game after 9/11 there was a real
focus on connecting the dots between
what seemed like disparate events have
we no longer are we no longer as careful
about connecting the dots anymore I
don't think so and I worked in this
environment for quite a while and I'll
tell you the FBI operates under very
severe resource constraints and legal
restraints into what it can do and how
it can do it so there are different
levels of investigation that the FBI can
take based on the information it has
coming in about whether someone poses a
threat and one way or another what you
had here was the most basic level which
was a basic interview and at the end of
the interview two FBI agents wrote a
memo saying interviewed ask the
questions no derogatory information
recommend no further action that memo of
course will be the subject of subsequent
congressional oversight hearings further
steps wiretap physical inspection
interviewing of relations all the
different things the FBI can do can't be
done until there's better what the we
call predication I was asked a question
this weekend I didn't know the answer
for maybe you have it how many are in
this country like these brothers is it
50 thousand ten thousand ten and what
would happen here might it sounds like
what we call preliminary investigation
of PII and the FBI opens them all the
time and quickly closes them out I'm not
the least bit surprised they had had a
previous encounter with these two
individuals in fact last week and all of
our discussion about I suggested that
was probably the case what is the
current state of surveillance for
homegrown terrorists like these brothers
might have been versus foreign
terrorists as a general matter in the
United States we do not can
the US government does not conduct
surveillance without reason to do so so
there's no broad-based collection as
there occasionally may be abroad to do
it to really surveil someone at home
they're private by which I mean they're
private communications it requires some
degree of proof that they in fact are a
risk of causing a certain kind of
violation and as you get up the to more
precise and more damaging forms of
violations you can get extremely
intrusive but in a general matter
there's no vacuum cleaner of
surveillance data on individuals inside
the country
we went from 2001 to 2013
where will our organization and
intelligence on terrorism be in 2020
it's an excellent question I think it
will at first it will depend on if
anything else happens I think this
attack will be an impetus for some
reform on the domestic and law
enforcement side most of what we did
post 9/11 was really focused on the
external foreign intelligence and
military capabilities this the domestic
side got quite a bit of attention but I
think this will remind people that we
still need to be vigilant and keep
working at home these brothers have a
lot of relatives in United States what
does all the events over the past week
mean for those relatives are they under
surveillance are they going to be
questioned more severely yes they will
all be caught they will all be
interviewed and looked at so what what
the law enforcement community will do is
contact trace the two brothers and go to
everyone who they're in contact
relatives friends teachers mosque Imams
at the mosque every one and they will
build the dossier on them and at some
point they may approach them to be
interviewed either consensually or in an
adversarial way some of them may be
charged if it's found that they either
lie to law enforcement or assisted or
abetted the attack this is CIA involved
in any of this absolutely what are they
generating from the FBI they run down
the foreign leads so the FBI has certain
formal channels to go to foreign
governments for assistance but the CIA
has more CIA operates abroad in many of
these countries there's the CIA station
in Moscow there's a CIA presence in the
Caucasus their job will be to find out
what's really going on on the ground